[Music]
foreign
rare matpat jump scare hello Internet
welcome to film Theory where today I'm
gonna tell you a ghost story so if
you've ever watched even a fraction of
my stuff that I do online you'll know
that I was a theater kid oh the Places I
would like to show a big theater kid no
device is a safety tonight
like I said just pure unadulterated
theater trash and it goes all the way
back to when I was in kindergarten for
my first career day I actually remember
that I dressed up in a suit and a tie
here was everyone else in their cute
little firefighter hats of their
doctor's coats or whatever and here I
was little mini mat Pat looking like the
world's teeniest tiniest accountant when
adults asked me what I was dressed as I
would say I'm an actor because
apparently I thought actors were the
fanciest most nicest clothing out there
how wrong I was as most of you know at
this point I went to college for a
combination of theater and Neuroscience
and while I was there I tried to do as
many shows as humanly possible I played
every role from a neurotic manservant to
a neurotic Court Jester to uh to an
erotic Halloween monster in other words
I had range that's what they would call
it in the business but there was this
one semester where I don't know just
everything that was being produced
looked boring the musical was one I'd
done before and the theme Department
show was what theater Department shows
always are at colleges something
esoteric and weird
I am commenting on this couch
I am commenting on the Teeny cubby in
this room this is what my character
would choose also can I just say I love
the full 360 Tour that you're getting of
the GTA live studio right now anyway I
loved all of this stuff like I said pure
theater trash and after all if I was
going to be making a career in theater
this is my job right so I could not be
doing a show for a couple months so I
did what was probably the unthinkable I
crossed Enemy Lines I went to audition
at the Rival School
can we fire up like a dramatic chipmunk
or what's a good relevant version of
dramatic chipmunk these days
around and then Owen Wilson is like
walking all fabulous and it's like who
is she can I just say this I love that I
asked for a more relevant example than
the dramatic chipmunk and the response
that I got back was Zoolander
you know that classic Ben Stiller movie
that predates all of this uh honestly no
one had ever done that sort of thing
before because I guess no one had ever
really thought about it like oh you
could audition at the Rival school no
way well I did um and I don't know if I
can truly impress upon you how big of a
thing this was because I went to Duke
and it has like one of the all-time most
intense rivalries against the
neighboring school you know United
Church of Christ not the United Church
of Christ the University of North
Carolina or UNC for short and let me
tell you I pulled out all the stops for
this audition uh in general my auditions
tended to be
unique but they're Tango for this one in
particular I wanted to make a big
impression to the other schools so I
went in and I did a dramatic monologue
of Bet On It from High School Musical 2.
in case you've repressed your memories
over that Disney Original production
here's the Refresher
just look at that Disney Channel
Original Movie level water reflection
right there and and you heard me right I
didn't sing the song I said it as a
monologue not singing the struggles of
being Troy Bolton forced onto a golf
course here let me see if I can uh pull
up a moment here
everybody's always talking at me
[Music]
everybody's trying to get in my head
I've got to listen to my own heart
talking
I've got to listen to myself instead Bet
On It Bet On It Bet On It
bet on me long story short I clearly got
the parts the show was this crazy show
called you're in town which if you
haven't heard of it I'm not surprised
it's not super popular with a name like
you're in town it's actually a joke that
they write into the musical but uh it's
about this world where you have to pay
to pee because they've run out of water
you know theater shows gonna theater you
know what I'm saying anyway it was while
I was being a turncoat at UNC that I met
this girl named Haley who was a UNC Alum
who inspired by my Galaxy brained
maneuvering here actually crossed back
over to my school Duke to audition and
unlike me Haley was actually good like
legitimately very good like good enough
to perform in front of the entirety of a
packed Yankees baseball stadium roll the
clip
to the ocean
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
legit right she just casually dropping
the high notes in front of 46 000 sports
fans sure way to show off there honey
anyway Haley and I bonded over the fact
that we were the defectors the ones that
were willing to cross Enemy Lines as it
were uh we were casual friends all
throughout the rest of college we
graduate life happens everyone moves on
you know how it goes I become that Big
Nerd guy over on YouTube that part
you're probably a bit more familiar with
but then out of nowhere at the top of
this year I see a familiar name pop up
in my inbox it's Haley did
air it's been too long I am now the
mother of a six-year-old time happens
fast and my stepson who is a budding
video game composer he's amazing and his
favorite show to watch online much to my
surprise an old familiar voice from
college you pretty cool uh we watch you
every week I don't always understand at
all you and me both uh but you've made a
huge difference in his life thank you
um I'm saying all of this not to Humble
brag about like whoa look at how
important I was to her son's childhood
but rather for the context of what comes
next so this is complete random but I'm
producing shows on Broadway now you know
just casual drop-up just a big time
Broadway producer whatever and the
latest project come across my desk is
Gray House a psychological Thriller
horror play coming to Broadway this may
and I thought of you and Steph
immediately for this after years of
watching you I just feel like this would
be such a fit because it combines horror
mystery and theater and it would be
introducing a brand new genre to
Broadway which is it's so craving let me
know if you'd like to get on a phone
blah blah et cetera Etc definitely a
different email than I was expecting
there but uh long story short we said
yes to meeting with Haley and honestly
that's how we learned about what the
show was which is really cool a couple
gets into a car crash during a blizzard
up in the mountains and winds up trapped
in this mysterious cabin inhabited by a
group of strange girls who get this may
or may not be dead
a lot of alarm bells ringing a lot of
theorist checkpoints there there's this
strange glowing that's coming from the
basement there are pentagrams carved
into the floor there are monsters
literally crawling out of the walls and
throughout the whole thing you have
hidden messages sprinkled throughout
hidden in stuff like Morse code and sign
language I mean put your jazz hands Away
Ladies and Gentlemen Hamilton this is
not and the whole thing star Sophia and
Caruso from Beetlejuice Tatiana mazlani
from She Hulk and Millicent Simmons from
a quiet place and the whole thing is
being directed by the director who did
Wicked like it is a stacked creative
team but uh let's be honest none of that
mattered they had me the second they
said dead kids so we said yes to
investing in Gray house now normally
what that would mean is that you just
write a check that's all it is you
literally are just helping to support
the Arts with a bunch of other people
because creating theater in New York is
expensive and hey if the show goes well
you get some of that money back awesome
but surprising literally no one still
Steph and I weren't just content to
leave it alone you guys know that we are
type A personalities well I'd go so far
as to say we are type A Plus
personalities because if we're doing a
thing then we are doing it doing it so
Steph and I are all like hey you know we
have 12 plus years of experience solving
spooky Mysteries and horror things
online I think there's a little bit more
that we can do to help the production
since this is a horror and mystery show
maybe I don't know have you thought
about doing some dances over on Tick
Tock or maybe an influencer night how
about nargy let me sit you down and talk
to you about how Jimmy Neutron crosses
over into the GrubHub universe
they were a bit confused and so we met
more and more of the marketing team and
the creative teams that were putting the
show on and we had some calls that were
full of some of the biggest names in the
theater world and let me tell you at
first those calls were
I mean I gotta befraid they were
uncomfortable let me explain why you see
we have like I said I've been doing this
for 12 years we know this world if I
tell the editors to do this
when you're not really fine but you just
right you know exactly what this means
you know what we're referencing or it's
something even more obscure if we do
this
or most obscure of all this
we all are chronically unlined so we
know the way and we also know why we
probably shouldn't be talking about the
way anymore but to the outside theater
world oh boy this whole thing this is a
big old black box actually it is worse
than a black box this right here this
digital video land it is the home of
Broadway's most dreaded two words slime
tutorials and we're not talking about
literal slime tutorials we're making
things for kids no my friends uh theater
has to be really restrictive when it
comes to filming shows because of all
the copyrights and Union rules and
performances involved each show is
allowed to just be filmed once and only
once for archival purposes that copy is
then stored in one very specific library
in a corner of New York but don't think
that you can just roll in and start
watching the original cast of
Beetlejuice on repeat no you absolutely
can't you can only watch that taped
recording one time in your entire life
and only if you can prove they have a
research-based reason to watch it in the
first place so in a world where we are
literally dripping in an access the
content let's just say that theater has
itself a bit of an accessibility problem
and as you see with any business a
problem of accessibility ultimately
gives rise to piracy or in this case
slime tutorials the secret coded word
for any bootlegged video recording of a
Broadway show in a world where people
want to see theater but just can't
because of all the restrictive nature
around it or the high price point slime
tutorials have basically stepped in here
on YouTube to fill in the Gap most of
them are really terrible quality they
are definitely illegal but if you really
want to see a show and you just can't
afford to or you can't make it to the
theater while it's performing well
that's what a lot of people have turned
to and to the people in the theater
world who don't understand our corner of
the internet that right there that is
what digital video is and so here we are
starting to roll into producer meetings
me and Steph Mr and Mrs internet video
asking hey guys have you ever thought
about opening your doors and considering
letting theater influencers film bits of
the rehearsals or maybe get shots of the
set being constructed bring them along
long for the Journey of the show it got
awkward fast to them that was just
letting the Slime flow forth and it
didn't help either that theater is
literally one of the oldest art forms in
the world and Broadway it is like the
most entrenched of Institutions that
involve thousands of people to put on
these products but the coolest thing
about the process here was that at the
end of the day even though they were
nervous and they were definitely
uncertain about some of the stuff that
we were talking about they said yes at
least they kept an open mind to learning
more they wanted to be educated and bit
by bit we watched as the walls began to
erode between these two worlds there
started to be more conversation we
started to have more of the same
language yes to a YouTube strategy yes
to doing weird stunts like having creepy
demon girls wandering around Times
Square lurking in the backgrounds of
people's tourist photos to help promote
this thing virally yes to an influencer
night can you believe that this was one
of the first shows on Broadway if not
the first show to invite online creators
to a preview event film studios have
been doing that for a long time at this
point but theater this was like mind
blowing to them and let me tell you the
mood was electric people there were so
excited to be a part of this launch
event I finally got the chance to meet
with Thomas Sanders who I've been
wanting to meet for years but we're
always just like ships passing in the
night as well as Ron boo who you know we
cover a fair bit across the channels
there was also gamer from Mars waiting
the wings swell entertainment all people
that I love to watch I was sent an email
uh saying that I was invited to Gray
House on Broadway May 10th and I
immediately was like what do I know what
you're thinking Amanda why you I don't
know I still don't know I do Amanda it
was us it was us and the creative team
being fans of your work and wanting you
to be a part of this thing and now it's
been done right creators and Broadway
have finally crossed over and hopefully
now that it's been done once it's easier
to happen again and again and again and
we're already starting to see that
happen a week after we did that
influencer night the main creative team
asked Steph and I if it was a good idea
for them to start their own subreddit so
people could discuss the lore of the
show and solve it together online and
we're like yes absolutely that's a great
idea also you use the word subreddit
right a week ago that wouldn't have been
the case they were like hey do you think
it would be a good idea if we started to
give away free tickets with people like
that and we're like duh of course who
wouldn't want that sort of thing guys
it's not rocket science you know when I
started doing theories 10 12 years ago
ancient I'm literally dust I was living
in New York right I was on those streets
I was pounding the pavement in the
Theater District the show opened what
like two or three blocks away from where
I would wake up every morning get there
at 4am to stand in line for them to
finally open the door at 6am so I could
wait all day to try and get an audition
that never happened this was a time in
my life where splitting a Chipotle
burrito was the big meal of the week
because it was what Steph and I could
afford based off of the budget that we
had at the time and now here we are
trying to help shape this industry that
was so pivotal to my early life we're
trying to update it we're trying to make
it exciting and alive for a brand new
generation of artists and fans and
that's
it's kind of unreal I let you guys know
over on game theory that I was going to
be there for the opening week of the
show and because this is a show with
mysterious lore that you just want to
discuss with your friends in order to
solve we even did a talk back with all
you theorists in the audience and while
I've done just so many too many to
counts when it comes to talkbacks and
presentations and on stage performances
and whatever this one was special I mean
this was on a Broadway stage I mean it's
not an exaggeration to say like this was
literally kindergarten matpat stream
come true hello Broadway
welcome to the gray house TalkBack
everyone look there it is my bio in a
Broadway program and I'm gonna flash it
up on screen real quick for you to breed
uh there's an ARG in there we're like
well if we're in a Broadway Theater like
might as well throw in an ARG mystery
for you to solve that alone would have
made it enough like wow this is
incredible I get to stand on a Broadway
stage and talk like that was awesome but
then you guys showed up and let me say
that the theater was packed and the
conversation that we had about the show
it was it was incredible you guys are
amazing how many of you enjoyed the show
great
how many of you have questions about the
show
great yep that is totally to be expected
your theories about the show were
wonderful we haven't got to throw in a
Five Nights at Freddy's reference it's
the best jump scare ever eat your heart
out Five Nights at Freddy's Five Nights
at Freddy's on Broadway never thought
that crossover was gonna happen but that
is now on the 2023 bingo card if you
want to see actually the full TalkBack
that we did it is here on YouTube I'll
link to it in all the usual places the
show wasn't done when the theater closed
as we left there were just so many of
you out on the street a group of people
so big that without exaggeration they
had to shut the street down in front of
the theater I mean that right there that
was incredible we didn't get to actually
go to the after party celebrating the
show until hours after everyone else was
there because we were trying to spend as
much time as possible talking to you
guys Broadway opening right after party
we're here we're we're here what like an
hour and a half late yeah it's okay it's
all right I was told by one of The
Producers on the show that this is the
sort of thing that doesn't tend to
happen on Broadway but you guys you made
it happen the reason I'm telling the
story now is because it's time for the
production to wrap up we're revving up
for the final performances we're getting
ready to close the doors so now felt
like the perfect time to actually just
tell you this story one that has just
been a tremendous Personal Achievement
for me and a testament to everything
that we as a collective theorist
Community has been able to do together
so if you do want to be a part of that
history and see how the show comes
together before all record of it gets
relegated to a random New York Library
in the corner grab a ticket now my
friends link is in the description in
fact if you use the code GH theorist you
can save 10 bucks on your tickets not
only is the show awesome it's mysterious
it's scary it's thought provoking but
also it takes place in a haunted theater
nothing to see there just a ghost in the
corner
oh it's a pipe and while I couldn't
certainly just end the video right here
now hey that's a theory of film Theory
but it wasn't blah blah I do want to
leave you with one last thing you see
this show also an incredible showcase
for both hearing and non-hearing actors
using sign language all throughout the
presentation and through this process I
was actually fortunate enough to speak
to the director of artistic sign
language Andrew Murillo who spoke to us
about the evolution of sign language and
how it's used throughout this show it's
long but it is a fascinating clip which
is why I wanted to share it with you
here right at the end so enjoy that as I
leave you here and as always my friends
remember it's just a theory a film
Theory and scene you mentioned setting
and taking into account setting do
different settings come with different
considerations when teaching things
around sign language or creating the
language of the world that you're
putting up on stage yeah absolutely so
Gray House is set in the 70s we signed
differently in the 70s than we do now so
we have to figure out exactly how to
represent that way we signed in the 70s
in this show so we have a deck character
in the show and we have some ASL in the
show but that's just one part of the
story it's not the featured part of the
story it's just that one of the
characters happens to be deaf in this
world we don't want the sign language to
essentially pull focus on the story it's
just that we have a deaf character in
the story could you give us an example
of something that would be different
today than it was in the 70s just so we
could get a visual cue of that sure yes
so ASL we don't have so much
documentation of the actual language
because there's no written form of ASL
whereas with English we can see how it's
changed from you know Shakespearean
times up until modern times but we
didn't have the technology in the 60s
and 70s to fully document our language
and kind of codify it for the masses but
I will give you a simple example so in
the 70s we used to sign an English word
order rather than in our American Sign
Language grammar let's take the example
the sentence who are you today we would
sign it like that this but in the 70s we
would sign
who are you so these are little nuances
they might not seem like a lot to you
but definitely the deaf audience that
comes to see our show will be able to
appreciate and take in those nuances are
there any techniques that you use to
help the actors learn sign with sign
language faster or how does that
teaching process develop we usually have
ASL sessions built into the rehearsal
I'll talk with the actor about their
character what they think works for
their character why are you standing in
that moment why are you not signing in
that moment and then I get into the text
and start teaching them the translations
I record myself with those translations
and send it to them so they can work on
their own I have to say that this cast
has been phenomenal with learning sign
language they're all such quick studies
they learn so much in such a short
amount of time we have such an amazing
cast so grateful for all of them
[Music]